I think deep down in the heart and soul
of every individual they want to know
that they really count they want to know
that what they do really matters I've
actually learned that eighty-two percent
of employees believe that they're not
recognized by their supervisor for what
they do and sixty percent of employees
say they actually like recognition as
much as money and we've also learned
that recognition happens very rarely you
know the average person in any company
gets recognized if they're lucky about
once every two months and what I want to
do is is is spend the rest of my life
really building awareness of this fact
and and really driving home the fact
that you know as leaders and as as
family heads you know our job is that to
let people know that they're really
recognized for the great gifts that they
have and all the contributions they
bring to it to the to a business and
into the world the job of the leaders to
create that work environment where
people know that that you care about
them and once you care about them as a
leader I guarantee you they're gonna
care about you it's sort of like this
you know I've never liked anybody that
didn't like me I bet you haven't either
I've never really trusted somebody that
didn't trust me and so if you want to
get people invested in you boy show them
that you care about them and then
they'll care about you and they'll care
about the company more and they'll come
to work every day wanting to do all they
can to make the company a success the
best way to recognize somebody is to is
to listen to them when you listen to
them you show that you really care if
you listen and the two things happen
number one you actually learn something
because these people know a lot about
your business and if you can just
basically say listen if you add my job
or if you could give me some input what
it would it be and then you listen to
what they have to say and then you
respond then you're showing that you
actually care I think there's two
reasons why people don't recognize other
people number one they think if they do
they don't trust people they think oh
they're not going to work hard enough if
I recognize you and tell you're doing a
good job you'll take the pressure off
the off your
you won't put the pedal to the metal
anymore so you won't work as hard which
is absolutely crazy people work harder
when they know that they're they're
really being noticed the other thing is
if I recognize you boy somebody else is
going to wish they're gonna get
recognized and you know what what's
wrong with that you know find what
they're doing to and recognize their
behaviors that are driving your business
thank you in my mind I don't know if
it's one word or two words like
sometimes I get confused about that but
thank you is the most powerful phrase in
our language it says I appreciate what
you do I noticed it it's not that hard
to do you know it's why we teach our
kids to say thank you I mean it's a it's
a it's it's important but if you don't
say thank you you're not noticing what
people do you're you're actually taking
advantage of what they do in my mind and
how hard is it how hard is it to say
thank you it's not that hard and it's
very very powerful when you do it you
know one of the things you may notice by
my hairdo is that you know III have
usually I have a full head of hair but
you know I discovered about three or
four months ago that I have male breast
cancer which is a very rare rare thing
and one of the things I'll tell you
about having cancer you know thank god
you're not hit by a bus you know you're
hit by a bus it's over you know if you
have cancer you have the opportunity to
tell people that you love you love them
and then you also have the opportunity
to have people tell you that they love
you and that's an unbelievable thing
that really it's it's almost in its own
way it's it's a blessing and but it's
really made me stop and reflect you know
gosh what if you were hit by a bus you
know what if you hadn't recognized that
person what if you hadn't told a family
member or a friend or associate how much
you appreciate him you know what a waste
what a waste and I think you know this
is really driven home to me even more of
the importance of recognizing others and
appreciating people and letting people
know just how much you value them and
you know doing it for people who really
are deserving that's a joy that's a joy
of leadership and
think it's a joy of being a good human
being